coming up now all right we know you've
been waiting to hear more about this
game since it was announced back in
April and now it's time for a deep dive
into the world of Vikings my name is
Julian Fei and I'm the producer of
Assassin's Creed Valhalla so a couple of
weeks ago we announced Assassin's Creed
Valhalla and the reaction from the fans
was just amazing the time period of
Vikings is really really inspiring when
we did our research we found that you
know they were not mindless barbarians
the Vikings were actually farmers trying
to find new lands for them to settle and
so they had really human motivations so
for us to have this opportunity to tell
could have the real story about Vikings
and kind of separate ourselves from the
myths and the folklore is really
something that drove us that to make
this game the team went to Norway in
England take the same roads that the
Vikings did to really experience what it
meant to be a Viking at that time and
then leaving Norway which is barren but
majestic and just coming by boat in
England and see those rolling green
hills full of sheep full of life is just
this moment that most likely the Vikings
felt as well you need to see this land
of opportunity and this is exactly the
feeling we want players to experience in
this game
[Music]
it is a personal adventure you know it
is the story of a for a Viking chieftain
a4 is either a male or a female you
decide when you start the game they will
have to leave Norway to settle in
England because you just can't live in
Norway anymore there's too much
political pressure no resources
available obviously in England
it's full of anglo-saxons and other
people and they don't really want you
there so you will have to fight your way
there to kind of build your own
settlement and see your clan prosper
Vikings were brutal warriors
and the fact that they were mastering a
lot of weapons coming from the medieval
times really inspired us to kind of
revamp the fight system to leverage the
brutality and the intensity of Viking
combat Vikings were not only fighting
face-to-face they were masters of
stealth and deception when needed they
used basically any sort of tactics they
could use to win the battle so we want
to portray the full range of combat that
you can imagine coming from the Vikings
we are very happy to finally be able to
show you the game we're all been working
on so please enjoy this deep dive into
Sasson screen Valhalla
[Music]
in Assassin's Creed Valhalla you will
relive the epic saga of the Viking
invasion of England
you play as a var a Viking from Norway
who would lead his or her
battle-hardened warriors across the
North Sea to the British Isles a var is
driven by an ambitious goal to build a
thriving Norse settlement in a hostile
land it is time we go a Viking today we
raise that tomorrow we may build England
is a Dark Age tangle of broken kingdoms
and warring dynasties a land of
opportunity and riches as you prowling
lers rivers by longship you may Rhea
locations you spot from the shoreline
ground your ship and blow your horn to
lead your raiding crew into battle
your crew will assist you in all your
raids fighting enemies battering down
doors and stealing cargo too heavy for
one set of arms whatever riches and
resources you pillage may be used to
develop your settlement giving you
access to useful services better tools
and new settlers at the heart of your
settlement is the Alliance map it will
serve as a record of the allies you have
made and a guide for future
opportunities the Viking Age was a time
of warriors and legends in Valhalla you
will find the largest variety of enemies
ever assembled in an assassin's Creed
game in free archetype offers a unique
challenge some will coordinate with
their allies for special attacks while
others will use nearby objects to their
advantage
including the bodies of fallen warriors
to face these attacks you must find and
exploit your opponent's weaknesses to
gain the upper hand take the fight to
your foes with a host of brutal new
combat abilities snare them with a
vitamin harpoon pummel them with
throwing axes
incapacitate them with the new stun
system to keep them at a distance or
finish the Marvel dual wield any two
weapons you wish to unleash a deadly
combination of attacks
customize your fighting style as you see
fit and become a legendary Viking
warrior
all combinations of weapons are
available to dual-wield including to
shields
not all situations call for violence in
this new land a Viking must find a way
to adapt as a Ivar is not welcome in
England you may need to outsmart your
enemies avoiding unwanted attention in
towns and bustling cities use a VARs
hoody and cloak to blend with crowds and
slip past watchful eyes an unseen hunter
among the people
from capital cities and villages to the
dense forests and rolling hills of
England exploration is vital to keeping
yourself sharp you must feed off the
land if you hope to endure hunt and
forage to replenish your health and
fortify your equipment such pagan
temples and Roman ruins for new
activities and challenges to strengthen
yourself and your settlement
the more you explore the more of
England's secrets you will reveal but as
you push deeper into England the enemy
will push back in a series of climactic
moments Assassin's Creed Valhalla will
feature massive assaults in which you
who lead a Vosges army into battle
against heavily guarded Saxon fortresses
today we fight for your land and
tomorrow we rebuild forests thirsty
Assassin's Creed Valhalla will transport
you to wondrous and haunted lands
inspired by Norse myths and England's
pagan roots it will challenge and
surprise thank you
with unforgettable characters thrilling
triumphs and tragic losses giving you
the chance to with your own Viking saga
[Music]
ninth century England is truly unlike
anything the franchise has seen before
Assassin's Creed Valhalla
were released this holiday season on
Xbox